[Music]
hi
it's me miss coffee bean i was
very busy in the last weeks and i
almost missed that we passed a thousand
subscribers mark
thankfully mr coffee cup offered to
write the script for this video
mr coffee cup is the script ready
here it is thousand subscribers
video by mr coffee cup
first i want to say thank you to all my
subscribers
oh tony tony yo
actually i don't even know if it's 270
270 subs or something but 270
subscribers
is a milestone for me and to all y'all
y'all are amazing
thank you for liking my channel thank
you for subscribing
thank you yesterday was a bad day for
all of y'all
and it was darn cold okay
what is this crap
mr coffee cup what is this
what you were too lazy to write the
script so you train the bots to write it
for you
oh you say the subscriber milestone
videos are all the same
so a bot should easily be able to do it
for you
well it really didn't work did it
[Music]
oh there's more oh okay let me see this
second attempt okay so as soon
as i hit so as soon as i hit thousand
subscribers
it was like this was not in 2017
so out of all my mathematical equations
and human nature
always sciences have contended over the
past 150 years
so my goal with this video is to excuse
the giant
cloud that is my computer science
trained predictions for behavioral
analysis and reinforcement learning
i but i also want to point out
that audience members should heed the
warning signs and remain
monitored
well at least this time it seems to be
about machine learning
anyway how did you do this
okay so you searched youtube for
thousand subscriber videos and extracted
the subtitles of over 60 of them
you then use them to fine-tune the
pre-trained gpt
2 transformer model and then you let it
generate the script
okay let's look at another one i hope
this one's better
third attempt by mr coffee cup okay
let's go there's a problem and i'm
fixing it
yeah it seems like that and i'm hoping
that you guys are healing well okay it's
corona times okay
and i'm hoping that you guys are using
the forums
and if you don't use the forums then you
really don't know what the hell is going
on
and i'm sorry if i am
and i'm sorry if i let you down
really bad really bad really
really bad okay this has gone really
really bad
[Music]
so this was a common problem the mother
often started to repeat itself and was
difficult for it to get out of the
situation like that
come on mr coffee cup there must have
been at least
one good result right what about
this one fourth attempt by mr coffee cup
music okay here we are guys
thousand subscribers we made it to our
first milestone
so we're doing pretty good
we're growing we're doing great and
we'll see you
in the next video great that worked
perfectly
what do you say should we do one last
one
let's see it nice
nice nice nice nice
it's nice
music nice nice
okay it seems like gpt2 has really
picked up a
pattern here nice
okay i'll be back with a real video soon